let's go to the phones and see what is on
people's minds today.
The phone number is of course (617) 830-4750
and we will start today from our caller from
the seven three seven area code color from
seven three seven.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hello.
That is you.
It this Bay.
Yes, it is.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um, so I was about to ask a question.
Yep.
Um, it's on the topic of climate change.
It has been estimated that by the year 2050,
there will be 200 million climate refugees
in countries such as New Zealand, which I'm
from, right?
We have deported climate refugees when those
people have been in need.
And I also understand that Donald Trump has
some very inhumane policies at the border
and in regards to rejecting asylum seekers
that are coming in to the United States, I
wonder what the rate of job losses that are
estimated to come about due to automation
in the next 20 years.
We have, we could see the rise of horrific
demagoguery and potentially a sort of fascist
line and a fascist in a fascist way of thinking
more and more in our politics.
Yeah.
So that's interesting the way you phrase it
and frame it because the climate refugee crisis
is going to your so, so okay.
On the one hand you will have people like
me who have been saying, you need to understand
that climate destabilization is a national
security issue.
It is a population issue.
It is a public health issue because it has
these externalities.
We're eventually, people are going to need
to go somewhere else.
On the other hand, it is going to be you.
I mean it's like, listen, we already know
how the anti-immigrant right is going to use
it.
They'll say this now justifies making our
immigration law even more draconian and [inaudible]
and honestly, they will probably convince
some people with those arguments.
Uh, probably.
Yeah.
Um, there has to be a massive cultural shift
to take place.
Yeah.
S um, recent examples like say what the Australians
are doing, which I do recommend you pay attention
to with detaining refugees on Madison [inaudible]
become more and more mainstream.
I could see some horrific possibilities become
the case.
Who's to say that a, you know, he's the site
us Navy won't simply reject and asylum seeking
vessel coming in from say the Pacific right
from a nation such as care about and to for
Lou and tow that boat out into un-see where
the waters and leave and and leave a VSL that
is unseaworthy to simply sink.
Of course, if Donald Trump was president in
30 years, the logical extension of his attitude
today towards immigrants would be, Hey folks,
we're closed the, but you just, you can't
come in.
We're closed.
Boat's going to have to go somewhere else.
I mean, I don't think it would even be remotely
surprising that that's how he would react
to the scenario.
Your, your outline.
Yeah, for sure.
I just see this situation as being so damn
diarrhea.
There's no other way for me to put it.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
We're going to have to bleep that and I appreciate
your phone call and a very well-made point
and we will build up that and we will be in
very good shape.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the phone call.
We will talk to you soon.